تشتد المعارك بالخارج ويشتد الخنق على
هؤلاء طلاب جامعات ربما يتلقون درسهم
الاقصى تحت سطوه معركه حاصرتهم لعده ايام
جميع مبادره
في الغاز السريع الوضع الراهن لانه نحن لا
يوجد لدينا مؤن لا يوجد لدينا مؤن ولا
يوجد لدينا اطعمه وفضلا من
الطائرات تجوب تجوب في الخارج
ونتخوف نتخوف جدا جدا من انقطاع التيار
الكهربائي
وانعدام المياه
هؤلاء ليسوا افضل حالا مضت ايام ثقيله
مراهقون لا تتجاوز اعمارهم الثلاثه عشر
عاما احتجزوا في مدرسه طالت دوام فيها لا
تهمهم قواعد الحرب بعيدا ولا هم مدركون
مناشدات عمت مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
لانقاذ طلاب الجامعات والمدارس والعاملين
فيها بعضها خلى من الطعام وحتى الاسعافات
الاوليه للمصابين
الهلال الاحمر السوداني اعلن عن اخراج 450
طالبا محاصرا من المدارس لكن يبقى العشرات
من طلاب الجامعات في وضع حرج بلا اي
مساعده
صمت المكان هنا بين الجدران تقابله معركه
على اشدها في الساحات
ففي احياء مدينه الخرطوم تستمر الاشتباكات
بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع ما
اودى بحياه نحو 100 مدني واصابه 400 اخرين
وسط مناشدات من نقابه الاطباء بفتح ممرات
انسانيه لنقل المصابين وتسهيل وصول
الاطباء الى المستشفيات غيداء السالم
العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات